le corps repêché au large de l'irlande
serait bien celui d'eric tabarly la
certitude sera acquise demain après
autopsie mais la famille se dit dès
aujourd'hui parce que convaincu pour le
lendemain du scandale festina six
équipes ont subi ce matin des contrôles
sanguins sur le tour la double victoire
des français laurent desbiens et jacky
grand nous redonne des couleurs à cette
septième étape avec un mois d'avancé la
chasse aux oiseaux migrateurs est
ouverte dans 14 départements selon la
loi votée à l'assemblée manifestations
d'écologistes dans le pas de calais
charles trenet entraîne les festivaliers
de bretagne avec ce tour de chant plein
air à 85 ans il a toujours de la joie
pour notre plus grand plaisir
la mode avec le défilé haute couture de
jean paul gaultier en forme d'hommage à
gré ou à barbara le style boîtier du
cuir des plumes et de la fourrure
madame monsieur bonsoir selon la famille
d'éric tabarly il ya de fortes
présomptions pour que le corps repêché
vendredi au large de l'irlande soit bien
celui du navigateur disparu en mer c'est
un ami d'éric tabarly qui aura pour
charge d'identifier demain à l'hôpital
de waterford le corps une fois c'est sur
place valérie fournier jacques gérard
ici la mer les irlandais la connaissent
mais ils savent que rarement aileron les
corps qu'elle a emporté la nouvelle de
la découverte du corps d'éric tabarly en
a surpris plus d'un add-on le risque
comme alan fils de pêcheur ils étaient
présents vendredi quand le bateau de
pêche français a accosté avec à bord
la dépouille d'un homme
ils se disaient très choqués c'est un
site est difficile pour eux c'était pas
facile d'avoir un accord comme ça le
patron a dit que j'avais le nom eric
tabarly écrit sur le pull over sur le
corps ses patrons pêcheurs qui l'a vu
oui le corps a été retrouvé à quelques
dix milles nautiques de l'endroit où
eric tabarly a disparu il ya un mois
c'est un bateau semblable à celui ci qui
l'a repêché dans ses filets c'est assez
rare base de mc est courant et personnes
âgées dans les grands-fonds le pire
c'est rare de plus chez quelqu'un puisse
y retravailler
d'un grand monsieur c'est ce à quoi la
dépouille repose actuellement à la
morgue de l'hôpital de waterford au sud
de l'irlande
la police locale reste prudente sur
l'identité du corps même si elle a
retrouvé sur lui notamment un ciré jaune
et un pantalon de coton rouge la tenue
préférée d'eric tabarly certains
éléments et des vêtements que nous avons
retrouvée sur le corps nous laisse
croire qu'il s'agit bien de monsieur
tabarly mais pour l'instant nous ne
confirmant pas d'identification
l'autopsié aura lieu demain car les
enquêteurs irlandais attendait de
recevoir la fiche dentaire d'eric
tabarly qui ne leur est parvenue
seulement ce matin par fax seule la
comparaison des deux dentition leur
permettra d'identifier le port avec
certitude et pour l'instant la femme
d'eric tabarly et ses amis les plus
proches ne compte pas revenir en irlande
sauf s'ils doivent rapatrier
les suites de l'affairé festina sur le
tour de france la suspicion de dopage
sur le peloton mais aussi sur l'ensemble
du milieu sportif s'installe dans les
esprits
bernard hinault et leurs enseignants
appellent à éliminer les pourvoyeurs et
souhaite que l'enquêté aille jusqu'au
bout
dès ce matin six équipes à brive avant
le départ de l'étape ont subi des
contrôles sanguins olivier galzi et
jean-pierre pasteur le vainqueur du jour
jacky durand une victoire qui donne
automatiquement de privilèges à
l'arrivée les interviews et le contrôle
antidopage
y aller tranquillement va si on va
essayer d'y arriver parce qu'avec la
forte chaleur qu'on a eu on a dû perdre
des litres et des litres d'eau pour
faire depuis l'arrivée ben je bois des
litres et édite aussi pour pouvoir un
puriner après mais il y aura pas de
liste en gare de simples contrôles
d'urines les prises de sang elles se
font le matin
en tout six coureurs aujourd'hui seront
contrôlés à l'arrivée là ça sent les
numéros des coureurs qui vont être à
leur contrat nécessairement être
contrôlés ils ont été désignés il ya un
quart d'heure avant d'arriver au combien
de temps pour finir au contrôle 30
minutes
et sinon sinon ils sont dix héritiers
mais tous ces contrôles ne permettent
pas aujourd'hui de révéler la trace des
dopants nouvelle génération problème il
faut immanquablement que l' affaire de
dopage sorte de du tour de france des
journalistes des coureurs des
organisateurs qui n'ont qu'une expertise
médicale et que les hommes de sciences
viennent en quelque sorte à notre
seconde
ce qui n'est possible de faire ce qui
n'est pas possible de faire comment on
doit organiser les contrôles pour qu'ils
soient fiers car j'entends dire partout
les contrôles ne servent à rien ils sont
dépassés ne sont pas fiables et bien que
ceux qui savent cela nous expliquent
comment ils font pour eux deviennent
fiables
alors là nous aurons fait un grand pas
mais en attendant le tour continue avec
ses contrôles ses coureurs et ces
rumeurs où l'on parle maintenant de tvm
un mécanicien de cette équipe aurait été
arrêté en france en mars dernier en
possession de produits dopants
est ce que le mécanicien incriminé est
toujours avec vous maintenant je ne peux
pas vous dire je n'aime pas dénoncer
quelqu'un est ce que vous l'avez renvoyé
lui poser des questions je ne peux pas y
répondre
chez pvm on ne dit pas grand chose en
fait
comme chez festina hier on préfère
parler de la course et rien que de la
course
la double victoire française celle de
leur rendez bien nouveau maillot jaune
et de jacky durand vainqueur de la 8e
étape a redonné quelques couleurs au
tour de france mais n'a pas réussi à
consoler le public après le départ de
richard virenque ambiance le long des
routes où le sport reprend malgré tous
ses droits
alexandre kara n était légal et 24
heures après de festina sur le tour il
ne reste que la caravane publicitaire
les coureurs s'en sont allés mais à
chacun de leur passage les voitures
festina se paye un franc succès comme un
au revoir par procuration
c'est le champion c'est pas juste un cap
il ne faut pas que les hommes qui
prennent ou si on les accusés savaient
qu'ils soient jugés
moi coureurs du tour de france je
n'aurais pas pris le départ hier du
prologue à utiliser des produits pour
les aider un petit peu si la course a
repris ses droits le malaise lui
persiste le long des routes les
banderoles sont nombreuses mais pour
tous et d'abord une prise de conscience
entre amis ou en famille on en discute
on rit contre c'est à dire pour la bonne
image du sport c'est vrai que c'est la
bonne décision mais sinon pour les
coureurs eux-mêmes c'est quand même très
serré je pensais qu'ils allaient voir le
tour de france mais la crise est là
cents
c'est vraiment pas le des performances
physiques ya quand même un soutien
derrière c'est pas exactement le corps
humain la machine humaine qui gagne quoi
c'est dommage peut-être pour les
coureurs mais je pense pas que tu ne vas
pas une pique est totalement dans le
dopage
je doute ça soit faire ainsi autant
étape après étape la ferveur du public
ne se dément pas à l'arrivée on applaudi
avec enthousiasme les héros du jour pour
le cyclisme et les coureurs on a le
regard des enfants
on ne veut retenir que le bon exemple le
tour de france ne pouvait pas rêver
mieux aujourd'hui double victoire je
vous disais il ya un instant des
français jacky durand enlever la 8e
étape à montauban signant ainsi la
première victoire française depuis le
départ quant à laurent desbiens
il s'est emparé du maillot jaune de
leader détenu par l'allemand jan ullrich
sous une chaleur caniculaire résumé de
ces quelques 190 km laurent frédéric
bollée
laurent desbiens a fait mieux que bien
il est ce soir le nouveau
you jaune du tour et au lancer de
bouquet de fleurs il est même très bien
et dans la série jours glorieux honneur
aux français puisque c'est jacky durand
qui remporte sa huitième étape entre
brive la gaillarde et montauban 190 km
disputée sous une chaleur torride toute
l'étape n'a donc été qu'une quête à la
fraîcheur au bien être difficile pour ne
pas dire impossible
le parcours passait par salviac rien que
le nom fait peur les conditions
climatiques 36 degrés à l'ombre qui
dictent donc leur loi et qui font
souffrir un relief cassant et des chutes
collectives rythme le début de course
même la présence du lot n'arrive pas à
calmer les esprits jacky durand déjà le
laval ou à vide ces bouteilles et pas
seulement dans sa gorge mais il est prêt
à se battre jusqu'au bout
ils sont sept échappés avec pratiquement
neuf minutes d'avancé sur le peloton
un peloton dans lequel on trouve jan
ullrich et ses coéquipiers une vraie
gare de rapprocher
l'allemand a renoncé à défendre son
maillot coûte que coûte à sa manière le
maillot jaune qui est d'ailleurs une
place fortifiée qu'il va falloir
reconquérir le sprint est lancé par
l'italien tapis mais c'est jacky durand
qui donc s'impose en force
le peloton lui concède finalement sept
minutes 46 secondes des biens devient le
nouveau leader 14 secondes devant ta
fille 43 devant durant jan ullrich
rétrograde à la 5e place au général
trois minutes 21 derrière des biens
juste avant les pyrénées
la messe n'est peut-être pas encore dit
sur le tour la chasse aux oiseaux
migrateurs s'est ouverte avec un mois
d'avancé dans 14 départements après
l'adoption plutôt controversés de la loi
votée par l'assemblée dans le
pas-de-calais quelques 200 écologistes
ont manifesté leur désapprobation
alors que des forces de police
s'interposer entre ces manifestants et
les chasseurs regroupés dans la réserve
naturelle du platier doit caroline marie
dominique maes barrage de céret et on
est dans l'impossibilité de circuler
librement dans cette réserve naturelle
c'est par la force on est bon
une réserve naturelle aux allures de
camp retranché
deux escadrons de gendarmerie mobile
empêchent les écologistes de rejoindre
les chasseurs il s'agit d'éviter les
affrontements
ça veut vraiment dire que cette réserve
naturelle elle appartient aux
braconniers et moi je sais pas si vous
avez vu cette tribu de crs en plus ils
sont protégés
c'est plus une réserve naturelle c'est
une réserve sur naturel qu'on a ici au
petit doigt le platier doit accueille
depuis vingt ans les espèces sauvages en
route vers le sud
le problème c'est qu'il accueille aussi
les chasseurs il est incongru de chasser
dans une réserve naturelle d'une part
qui protège les oiseaux migrateurs et
puis il ya peut-être des espèces de
gibier mais également les espèces
protégées qui n'ont pas terni mineurs
leur modification est en fait les
chasseurs mettent en péril ces niches et
les chasseurs eux revendiquent ces
quelques hectares
les huttes de chasse existait avant la
réserve et depuis les pouvoirs publics
qu'ils ont toujours toléré les gens ils
sont extrêmement attachés ils ont
travaillé comme des fous pour arriver à
un résultat comme celui là voyez comme
c'est bon comprenez à quel point on peut
être attaché à quelque chose aussi de
ses fabuleux quoi écologistes et
chasseurs sont au moins d'accord sur un
point ils veulent que l'état définisse
clairement les contours de la réserve
car la chasse ouverte hier va se
poursuivre jusqu'en février
commémoration ce matin paris sur
l'esplanade de grenelle de la rafle du
vel d'hiv commémoration du ca juillet
car en lieu le maire de paris jean
tiberi a déposé une gerbe à la mémoire
des déportés 56 ans après que des
milliers de juifs parisiens étaient
arrêtés par la police française pour
être parqués au vélodrome d'hiver avant
d'être déportés et puis cet après midi
charles millon s'est rendu à la maison
des enfants d'izieu à l'occasion de
cette journée de commémoration
la présence du président de la région
rhône alpes est élu je vous le rappelle
avec les voix du front national a
troublé la centaine de personnes
déportées enfants de déportés qui se
recueillaient ils ont conspué charles
millon
les secours commencent de s'organiser en
papouasie après le raz-de-marée qui a
déferlé sur la côte nord le bilan
s'alourdit d'heure en heure 600 corps
ont déjà été repêchés en redoutent que
le nombre de victimes dépasse le millier
les produits de première nécessité des
médicaments sont acheminés dans cette
région difficile d'accès thierry kurt et
24 heures après le raz-de-marée
le bilan n'est pas encore définitif sept
cent corps ont été dénombrés mais les
premiers secours avancent des chiffres
allant de 1000 à 15 cents morts j'étais
sur la côte dix minutes après le séisme
nous avons entendu comme une détonation
et là on a vu la mer c'est rêver les
déferlé vers le village
nous n'avons eu que le choix 1 courir
pour sauver notre vie alors j'ai
commencé à courir avec toute ma famille
à travers le lagon la bande de terre
abritait sept villages entre lagon et
pacifique dont il ne reste plus rien
trois vagues se sont succédé de 7 à 10
mètres de hauteur
le tremblement de terre qui a déclenché
le tsunami avait une force de 7 degrés
sur l'échelle de richter
son épicentre n'était qu'à 33 km de la
côte
la plupart des blessés ont des fractures
multiples les gens ont été emportées
coulé se sont noyées
je pense que des milliers de gens sont
portés disparus fin mai pour mieux ces
cantons survivants ils ont été frappés
par des arbres emporté par les vagues
l'opération de secours est organisé par
l'australie oui la zone ne permet pas à
des avions gros porteurs de se poser le
dernier raz-de-marée dans cette région
date de 1930
ce matin j'ai hozalem un attentat à la
voiture piégé a été déjoué dans l'une
des rues les plus passantes de la ville
une camionnette remplie de produits
chimiques devait exploser sur place on
redoute à présent de nouvelles
opérations meurtrières du hamas et c'est
dans ce contexte de crise qu'israéliens
et palestiniens ont entamé une rencontre
la première depuis des mois pour tenter
de désamorcer de réamorcer plus
exactement le processus de paix saint
lambert l'un c'est une véritable
catastrophe qui a été évitée de justesse
au volant de cette camionnette piégée un
palestinien est parvenue jusqu'au centre
de la jérusalem juin à 8h30 ce matin il
a tenté de faire fonctionner le
détonateur l'avant du véhicule a pris
feu désignèrent pas eu d'explosion le
terroriste est hospitalisé gravement
brûlé pendant de longues heures les
artificiers de la police ont neutralisé
le contenu de la camionnette notamment
des bonbonnes de gaz et des produits que
la censure militaire a interdit de
révéler comme d'ailleurs tous les autres
éléments de l'enquète les responsables
de la sécurité attribue cette tentative
d'attentât au mouvement islamiste qui
distille voulait torpiller ainsi la
rencontre ce soir entre le ministre
israélien de la défense le numéro 2 de
l'ol paie at elle à lire il rappelle
qu'il ya seulement huit jours à gaza le
jihad islamique avait promis la reprise
des attaques suicide
alors que le sheikh yassine le chef du
ramasse a répété que son organisation
poursuivre la lutte contre israël
en début d'après-midi benyamin netanyahu
a réitéré ses exigences envers
l'autorité palestinienne notamment en
matière de sécurité
tout cela n'est pas de bon augure pour
la reprise du processus de paix nouveau
risque d'embrasement au kosovo avec ces
deux derniers jours cinq violents
incidents à la frontière entre l'albanie
et le kosovo
ces affrontements auraient été
particulièrement meurtrier dans les
rangs des séparatistes où l'on
dénombrait aujourd'hui une centaine de
victimes et de nombreux blessés
côté diplomatie le gouvernement albanais
a vigoureusement réagi aux opérations de
l'armée yougoslave qui apparaissent
comme autant de provocations tout faire
pour ne pas se laisser entraîner dans un
conflit régional françois corner les
séparatistes albanais blessés dans les
embuscades des gardes-frontières de
yougoslaves ont été hospitalisés
aujourd'hui à tirana ce qui permet à
belgrade d'accuser l'albanie de
bienveillance à l'égard de ces
séparatistes qui mènent la lutte armée
pour l'indépendance de la province du
kosovo peuplé à 90% d'albanais
l'incident le plus grave s'est produit
hier dans cette région montagneuse au
sud ouest du kosovo qui était jusqu'à
présent le principal couloir pour
l'acheminement depuis l'albanie des
armes et équipements militaires au
profit des séparatistes selon l'armée
yougoslave un millier d'hommes tels
qualifie de terroristes auraient tenté
de franchir la frontière depuis le
territoire albanais près de djerrah
beach à pour pénétrer au kosovo les
gardes-frontières yougoslave aurait
abattu une trentaine de séparatistes qui
portaient tous l'uniforme de lui c'est
qu'à l'armée de libération du kosovo
vingt autres séparatistes kosovars
serait tombée aujourd'hui à orahovac
toujours au sud ouest de la province ont
révolte où les combats ce soir se
poursuivre
l'armée de libération s'efforce
apparemment de cerner la ville sur trois
fronts pour couper la retraite au serbe
cette attaque musclée de lui c'est qu'à
coïncide avec une visite dans la
capitale provinciale pristina située à
une quarantaine de kilomètres d'ici
d'une délégation de l'organisation pour
la sécurité et la coopération en europe
qui tentent de relancer au kosovo
les discussions entre les deux parties
la triste litanie des massacres en
algérie on se personnes ont été égorgés
la nuit passée au sud d'alger
alors que vendredi une quinzaine de
soldats auraient été assassinés lors de
l'attaqué de leur caserne
quinze jours après l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi sur l'arabisation du pays les
réticences se multiplient dans tous les
domaines y compris dans celui de la
santé les hôpitaux algériens continuent
comme par le passé d'utiliser la langue
française une force est de constater que
cette loi rendant obligatoire la rave
dans toutes les administrations et pour
le moment inapplicable reportage thierry
thulliez avec mort en douchant ainsi les
algériens viennent de tout le pays pour
s'y faire soigner à l'hôpital mustapha
rien n'a changé pour le visiteur
malgré l'entrée en vigueur de la loi sur
l'arabisation dans les allées le
français n'a pas disparu mais puisque
désormais toutes les interventions et
les correspondances doivent être rédigés
en arabe
l'administration s'est adapté ça s'est
fait progressivement on a commencé à
réviser les fichiers à skis et papiers
administratifs avec les en-têtes tout ce
qui est petit de notes tout ça ça a
commencé à se faire un amalgame alava et
aimer ce traitement le premier jour mais
il faut plus qu'une loi pour changer les
habitudes dans cette clinique publique
les consultations se font toujours en
français tout comme les ordonnances
le professeur breweries c'est qu'il est
en contravention avec les nouvelles
règles mais comment faire quand en
médecine l'enseignement universitaire
est dispensé en français et que les
médecins sont en grande majorité
francophone
l'application
de cette loi se fait ça ne se fait pas
de façon progressive amènerait
obligatoirement une exclusion très
rapide de l'ensemble de ses enseignants
parce que même si possible de s'exprimer
en arabe
il est impossible de dispenser un cours
de qualité dans cette langue
actuellement c'est précisément le sujet
d'inquiétude de ses étudiants futurs
internes
ils vont devoir exercer en arabe mais
leurs études ne les ya pas préparés
depuis l'indépendance
l'arabe est pourtant la langue
officielle et voilà quelques années déjà
que l'arabisation est à l'ordre du jour
sans grand succès le berbère et le
français comme l'arabe demeurent les
langues communes du pays car au delà des
discours aux accents nationalistes
il n'y a jamais eu de vraie volonté
politique pour qu'il en soit autrement
aux etats unis la vague de chaleur qui
s'est abattue sur le texas la louisiane
et l'oklahoma est à l'origine du décès
de 85 personnes pour la 13e journée
consécutive des températures atteignant
38 degrés ont été enregistrées au texas
les lieux publics disposant d'air
conditionné ont été ouverts à tous dans
certaines villes l'eau est maintenant
rationner en chine et à pékin notamment
les habitants où chaque année davantage
le sentiment que l'été de plus en plus
chaud 38 degrés en effet l'année
dernière mais pourtant les météorologues
affirment que les températures ont
tendance à baisser depuis 1940 isabelle
bechler et récent le braz dans la
capitale chinoise ont observé quelques
unes des stratégies anti chaleur l'été
entre 30 et 38 degrés et pékin est en
général très vite écrasé de chaleur
ce qui n'empêche pas les retraités de se
livrer à leur musique et à leur exercice
favori dans les parcs les to be quelques
roucoulades d'opéra de pékin est
l'instrument anti canicule au point
pichot l'éventail c'est pratique quand
on est assis avec un d'autres affaires à
l'étranger les gens ne savent pas des
ventes à il trouve pas sa pratique
nous on se sert depuis toujours
l'ombre des acacias est accueillante
dans les parcs pékinois mais elle suffit
rarement à rafraîchir l'atmosphère quand
le thermomètre dépasse les 35 degrés et
certains choisissent alors des moyens
plus radicaux les eaux du parc de
bahreïn ne sont plus réservées aux
plaisirs impériaux tout un chacun donc
accès à un plongeon en pleine ville
quand il fait chaud on vient à g en
mange des glaces
quand j'ai vraiment trop changer reste
chez moi j'ai la clim
dans le passé on ne pouvait pas avoir de
climatiseurs il n'y avait pas assez
d'éléments maintenant que la production
augmente et tout le monde peut en avoir
la maison à commettre des pains de glace
chez soi et dormir sur une natte de la
manne du gong tresses d'ail régulation
ainsi pour faire descendre la
température du corps la stratégie des
jeunes hommes qui doivent marcher au
soleil relève du strip tease partiels
obtenus ce serait pas convenable le vent
sur le ventre ça fait du bien le tricot
de corps roulotté sous les aisselles est
une spécialité locale
il semble qu'en chine la chaleur attaque
par l'abdomen contrairement à nous qui
l'avons dit on par la tête
autre partie du corps particulièrement
sensible ici le mollet une jambe
couverte et c'est tout un corps qui bout
il ne reste plus qu'à se re et sur le
fruit de l'été dans des pyramides
entière 30 à l'angle des rues de la
capitale
la courge occidentale la passe fraîchit
nul que n'importe quelle boisson en quoi
il m'en faut une tous les deux jours
pour les enfants facilement à calvé de
chaleur rien ne vaut la poussette à
claire-voie francs bon et la coupe caf
virale
on les talk pour éviter les brûlures
elle porte un grand bavard de coton ce
petit tablier c'est contre le soleil et
puis la nuit ça il dit qu'elle prenne
froid par le n'ouvrir quand on met le
ventilateur
bon d'accord c'est manche me tiennent
chaud mais au moins je ne laisse pas de
coup de soleil
moi je sors toujours torse
j'étouffe avec le moindre tissus à pékin
une rumeur tenace dit que les
thermomètres publics sont bloqués à 38
températures à partir de laquelle les
travailleurs peuvent rentrer chez eux
la météo dément mais des 36 on travaille
à mi temps
les entreprises doivent distribuer des
boissons et défrayer leurs employés
retour en france entre menton et toulon
300 bateaux en quadrillé aujourd'hui les
eaux de la méditerranée pour compte et
très minutieusement les dauphins et
autres cétacés
c'est la troisième fois que cette
initiative qui fait appel aux bénévoles
se déroule sur la côte d'azur
olivier ferrand jean paul guerlain
d'abord c'est la tante le bateau navigue
vers le petit carré de 8 km qui lui a
été attribuée au milieu de la grande
bleue puis tout d'un coup ils arrivent
ils sont au moins une trentaine
le voilier devient leur jeu il glisse
devant l'étrave
à bord c'est l'effervescence un moment
magique les dauphins ça fait toujours
rêver mais ensuite le but de la mission
reprend le dessus
il faut remplir les questionnaires
convient de grands troupeaux d'ovins et
pour les identifier c'est facile vous
avez le des scripts et à des cours
donnés leurs positions parce que c'est
d'aider d'autres avant se déplacer
et vont peut-être vu plusieurs fois donc
vous devez noter lors de rencontres de
ceux de ce troupeau à qu'on estime à une
trentaine de têtes et ce sont des dopés
par le ses dauphins bleus et blancs ne
resteront que quelques minutes avec le
voilier avant de repartir jouer avec
d'autres ou chassés mais à bord la
mission doit continuer comme les 300
autres embarcations engagées dans
delphis il faut prélever du plancton
pour l'analyser mais avant les résultats
une première constatation s'impose à la
radio on nous a raconté qu'il y avait
pas mal de baleines beaucoup dauphin des
espadons d'airé manta je pense que les
gens ont vu beaucoup d'animaux et ce à
une valeur primaire c'est à dire qu'elle
avait des ternes et est vraiment loin
d'être morte au contraire si rien n'est
plus beau à quoi m du monde et je crois
qu'il faut la protéger de plus en plus
cela la communauté scientifique
considère que l'expérience ne présente
que peu d'intérêt l'opération médiatique
ne servirait que de faire valoir pour le
delphinarium de mike riddle marine
landes
d'ailleurs un recensement scientifique
est prévue mais au fond tous sont
d'accord sur une chose il faut préserver
la méditerranée et pourquoi pas créer en
son sein un sanctuaire marin cette panne
semaine à biarritz plus de cent
cinquante mille personnes pour assister
aux plus gros rassemblement surf
d'europe sur l'écumé dans le sens de la
vague
jean-jacques du forez blaise grenier
à biarritz les adeptes de la pelle et du
soap ont un peu ringard dans le coin au
château de sable on préfère le surf
pourtant et malgré la bogue de ce sport
on ne recense pas plus de six mille
licenciés
si vous vous demandez pourquoi voilà la
réponse parce que c'est
extraordinairement difficile d'entrer en
contact avec tout le monde le surf est
un sport de liberté d'autonomie les gens
refusent beaucoup tout tous les cadres
et tout ce qui est discipline et
finalement les surfers n'est pas le
besoin de se faire encarté mais alors
combien sont-ils les cavaliers de
légumes
vingt mille cinquante mille cent mille
c'est un petit peu difficile de d'aller
aussi loin dans les chiffres
d'après les ventes de planches d'après
qui est un critère ça se tiendrait aux
environs de 25 ou 30 milles 1 mais pas
au delà
quoi qu'il en soit sur la vague il n'y a
pas que des dompteurs des plumes
il ya des emplois dans la région le sien
c'est près de 200 entreprises employant
plus d'un millier de personnes la glisse
ça marche fort surtout dans le domaine
du short et la chemise et le sofa
juillet en général elle se penche
clairement jeu très bien en sort très
bien finir le nôtre notre année en
octobre à six ans endormie en france ce
qui aiderait 100 millions de plus que
l'année passée
c'est une grosse progression +2 40%
puisqu'on est dans les chiffres sachez
que les cadors de la planche sont loin
de gagner des fortunes
un seul exemple en 96 et après six ans
de carrière le champion du monde kelly
slater n'avait amassé que 400 mille
dollars la même année en huit mois andré
agassi avait récolté neuf cent mille
dollars assez clair moi je m'occupe
essentiellement des meilleurs sur toi
européen et c'est vrai qu'au niveau
européen mais ça reste même pas des
smicards mais les rmistes du surf c'est
pas c'est pas des gens qui vivent qu'ils
peuvent vivre de leur sport quoi ils
vivent leur sport avec l'argent qu'on
leur donne mais il fait pas vivre
ça serait une carrière avoir une femme
et avoir une maison vassard gens qui
touchent et pourtant c'est dur d'autant
que sur l'eau il n'y a pas de ramasseurs
de balles pas d pour l'irak est encore
moindre monde porte
un constat que je ne suis pas le seul à
faire puisque certains ont imaginé des
robes montres vrai oui les remontées
mécaniques comme on voit la neige oui
c'est joël de rosnay qui aiment ça va ce
qu'il est dans le futur non je crois que
nos remontées mécaniques c'est celle qui
sont naturels c'est celle scellée baline
qui a autour des des digues tour des
épis on remonte naturellement donc
boulaire mon veille
ah non c'est pas pour nous l'on sait
nature sauvage brut de pomme
c'est comme ça que les touristes aiment
le sport parce que plus qu'un sport
c'est un mode de vie une vie rythmée par
la petite musique des déferlantes leur
façon à eux des fumées les jours et même
la nuit
sport loisirs ou moyen de transport leur
leur connaît en europe un véritable
engouement mais faute d' espaces
réservés ou aménager les rollers qui
n'ont droit de rouler ni sur les
trottoirs ni sur la chaussée se faufile
parfois dangereusement entre les
voitures les accidents se multiplient et
c'est pour mettre en place une véritable
prévention cas groupe d'assurances vient
de réaliser une première
des simulations d'accidents autrement
dit des crash-tests d'euros l'heure
remuent elle benoît claude sicard une
voiture roulant à 50 km/heure vitesse
limite en ville sur son chemin un roller
lancé à 20 km/heure
la vitesse moyenne pour ce type de
locomotion un choc violent qui aurait
été mortelles pour un être humain mais
heureusement il s'agit de simulation une
première d'ailleurs en europe pour
tenter de trouver une parade à la
multiplication des accidents de la
circulation impliquant des rollers le
relève sa bile dessus la tête contre la
vitre et a giclé à 19 mètres plus loin
en arrière
ils atteignent des vitesses relativement
important de l'ordre de 30 km/heure et
ont su café relativement difficile de
freiner la difficulté de freiner d'après
ces crashs tests
c'est le facteur essentiel expliquant la
gravité des accidents des rollers du
coup les patineurs earth l'obstacle avec
une force 25 fois plus grande que dans
le cas d'un piéton les rouleurs fort
loisirs à la mode chez les adolescents
et nouveau moyen de transport pour les
citadins en 97 1 millions 400 mille
paires se sont vendues en france 700
fois plus qu'il ya cinq ans seulement
voilà en sortant du magasin
personne ou presque ne s'est réalisé
ceux ci
des gestes techniques indispensables à
la sécurité des patineurs en ville mais
en france aucune formation sérieuse
n'existe il faut quelqu'un pour rouler
pour les enseigner le problème c'est
qu'actuellement c'est le roland
considéré comme un sport qui nécessite
un brevet d'état pour pouvoir enseigner
ce sport
seulement 6 des patineurs de plus en
plus présents sur les trottoirs avec les
piétons et sur la chaussée parmi la
circulation un véritable casse tête pour
les autorités une réglementation est en
discussion en france elle pourrait
aboutir cet été un statut du roller
proche de celui du cycliste
le fou chantant fait chanter la bretagne
charles trenet en plein air devant
quelques dix mille festivaliers porté
par le public charles trenet 85 ans
s'est mêlé aisément à la programmation
de la nouvelle génération avec louise
attaque ou johnny clegg
olivier piou messieurs libère tout le
week end
ils se sont relayés pour préparer les
sandwichs tenir la buvette ou assuré
l'ex mille trois cents bénévoles au
total tous originaires de cette région
du centre bretagne aux confins des monts
d'arrée avec un seul but assurer le
succès de ce festival des vieilles
charrues qui est avant tout le leur on
doit quand même s'entraider non on est
une petite ville le centre bretagne et
d'accra nous et on va montrer qu'on est
capable de faire quelque chose
j'espère qu'on va être conne et après ça
les prochaines il y aura cent mille
personnes
en trois ans il en aura 150 et aidants
disent entendre à 250 ou 300 mille trois
cent mille peut-être pas tout n'est pas
loin de cent mille sans doute pour cette
septième édition des vieilles charrues
un festival à la programmation des plus
éclectiques puisque capable de réunir
sur une même affiche deux fous chantants
indie pop et charles trenet
m
c'est notamment
ah oui
mais bon
oui jouer
c
voir paris il n'était pas question on
était trop bien à carré car la plupart
ont passé ces trois jours sur place dans
une sorte de woodstock champêtre où la
fed compte autant que les concerts un
succès qui doit beaucoup aussi un
argument de poids pour les spectateurs
souvent très jeunes
le prix des sens mal pour 25 groupes ça
fait même pas dit bell
on voit on voit le dis pas pour me
franck c'est cool quoi mais lorsque les
choses sérieuses reprennent il n'y a pas
photo c'est louise attaque qui fait un
carton
fort de ses quatre cent mille albums
envolés en quelques mois violon
énergique et voix rock le temps d'un
week-end les mélodies tantôt romantique
tantôt acide de la révélation française
de l'année ont déferlé en raz-de-marée
musicale sur la bretagne centrale
quand le cinéma investi les monuments
historiques le mariage du grand écran et
des vieilles pierres avec pour la
troisième année consécutive la nuit du
cinéma
l'exemple à champs sur marne où se
déroulent de nombreux tournages
notamment le film ridicule césar 96 à
utiliser les décors naturels du site
gérard dalmaz pierre moscovici les mains
au chant le château de champs-sur-marne
a été transformé en plateau de tournage
fin 95 ridicule c'est le titre du film à
utiliser la demeure pour le décor fin
xviiie choisi par le réalisateur patrice
loko la caisse nationale des monuments
historiques qui gère le château a voulu
réunir le lieu du tournage et le plaisir
de la projection in situ en organisant
une séance de cinéma de plein air sur
écran géant gonflé entre cour et jardin
ridicule histoire cruelle d'un
gentilhomme provincial qui vient se
frotter à la cour de versailles et qui
s'y pique
le nobliaux et tourné en ridicule par
les courtisans qui ne pense qu'à faire
les bons mots qui tuent
cette projection une première et c'est
l'honneur de chant l'occasion de voir
revoir une belle histoire un beau film
dans un beau chat
heureusement certains conservateurs
accepte les tournages malgré la crainte
des dégâts on a la chance en france
d'avoir
toutes les époques conserver deux
magnifiques enfin patrimoine est
éblouissant et puis nous de l'exploiter
alors moi est ce qu'il faut c'est
trouver des conservateurs qui veuille
bien nous ouvrir les portes
c'est pas toujours le cas et si on est
arrivé à champs sur marne
c'est passionnant d'autres dans d'autres
départements ne vont pas cueilli pareil
pour un producteur c'est l'idéal de
trouver un décor authentique tout près
pour le spectateur c'est le rêve de voir
le film dans son décor
sous le ciel
qui fait quoi
nuit c'était maladie
et couleurs
plus
tout le monde est content alors les
châteaux ouvriront peut-être un peu plus
leur green llosa chjama les collections
de la haute couture avec aujourd'hui le
défilé jean paul gaultier dans un cadre
très classique à la maison des
polytechniciens défilé de parisienne
rendant hommage à juliette gréco romy
schneider ou encore barbara côté cour
côté jardin le spectacle gauthier avec
du cuir des plumes et de la fourrure se
fumer elle régis m'a t il
il en vint à paraître et
au départ c'était une envie de gamme une
collection de couture après vingt ans de
prêt-à-porter jean paul gaultier voulait
se faire plaisir et peu importe que l'
aventure ne dure qu'une saison 4 ont
passé les commandes arrivent contre
vents et marées un atelier est née quand
tant d'autres fermes des brumes dont on
ne roule
et
on a forest le des cheveux
un brin de nostalgie juste ce qu'il faut
gauthier s'est souvenu de belles
parisienne qui marque ou marquèrent par
leur élégance famille schneider juliette
gréco sarah bernhardt barbara ou encore
brigitte bardot
sit in à jouer si tu t'imagines
d'affilée de 6 y est
si tu t'imagines ça ça va à lire et
toujours la saison des à la saison
vézins saison des âmes fille le
couturier plonge dans le mythe pour y
dénicher les bases de la modernité des
beauté éternelle parés de plumes et de
cuir et encore de fourrure nous sommes
en plein luxe en pourquoi bouder son
plaisir
20 30 40 robe au plus seront vendues les
en attendant la création progresse il
n'est ce pas là finalement aujourd'hui
la mission de la haute couture sahara
xamax va durer ainsi se termine ce
journal je vous en rappelle les
principaux titres le corps repêchés au
large de l'irlande serait bien celui
d'eric tabarly la certitude sera acquise
de mme après autopsie mais la famille se
dit dès aujourd'hui presque convaincu au
lendemain du scandale festina six
équipes ont subi ce matin des contrôles
sanguins sur le tour la double victoire
du français laurent desbiens et jacky
durand redonne des couleurs à cette 8e
étape dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinet demain soir à 20h vous
retrouverez daniel de ville alliant je
vous remercie de votre attention
excellence de fin de soirée
août